[Music]
hey everyone its Alicia Malone I am back
from South by Southwest Film Festival
that was so much fun
exhausting but really good time and now
I get to tell you about the films that
you can actually see in theaters and on
video and demand this week with this
episode of Fandango indie movie Guide
let's kick it off with a film that
played at Sundance
starring Woody Harrelson as a very
commercially guy with absolutely no
filter
it's called Wilson it's based on a
graphic novel by Daniel Close and Daniel
was also behind the graphic novel which
became ghost Wells Wilson may not be a
cult classic like that film but it is a
really sweet funny movie and Woody
Harrelson is excellent as this very
lonely guy who discovers that he has an
adopted daughter and so he goes to find
his ex-wife and then the two track down
their daughter and they become this
unlikely trio beautiful excuse me we
have tickets to wicked and me shut up
can't you see that this woman is having
a profound moment it really is a whole
metaphor for how a lot of people in
America and around the world feel today
very disenfranchised like they can't
find their own place like people don't
really accept them for who they are so
it has that layer to it it's also just
great to see Woody Harrelson yelling at
people that is quite a tattoo how's that
it's like the ultimate argument in there
what your job I want to destroy your
entire society Wilson is in select
theaters this weekend
and speaking of biting dark comedies you
have to check out pre venge by Alice
Lowe I saw this one at South by
Southwest and this is directed by Alice
her directorial debut it's written by
Alice she also co-wrote Ben Wheatley
sightseers which was another dark
disturbing film and she also stars in
pre Venge
as a recent widow who is pregnant and
her unborn fetus decides to tell her to
kill everyone as some sort of revenge
I'm not in control of it this is a great
example of a horror directed by a woman
because it really goes there it does not
hold back it's singular in its tone but
at the same time has a lot to say to
women particularly about anxiety over
your first pregnancy prepartum
depression I think a lot of women will
be able to relate to this it's a really
fun time at the cinema and has a lot to
say
so check out pre venge in select
theaters this weekend so these guys are
really spoiled like mummy I want a
Playstation mummy I want you to kill
that man
[Applause]
and on video-on-demand this week you
have to check out one of my favorite
films from 2016 this is the perfect
movie to watch in the comfort of your
own home it's called Patterson it stars
Adam driver as a bus driver named
Patterson who is living in Paterson New
Jersey it's directed by Jim Jarmusch and
it's all about those little coincidences
those little patterns and the beauty in
day-to-day life it just follows a week
in his life and nothing super dramatic
happens but it's so beautiful it's
absolutely moving and I love the poetry
in it so much so that one of my good
friends Matt actually bought me this
edition of the collected earlier poems
of William Carlos Williams this is the
same edition of a book that Adam drivers
character reads and in one of these
poems is in here and I loved it so much
I knock off work have a beer at the bar
I look down at the glass
and feel glad it's like a gorgeous
meditation on life
check out Patterson on video on demand
including Fandango now from March 21 a
bar survey in Patterson what is very
poetic
so to recap in theaters see Wilson or
pre venge and at home watch Patterson
all those films are well worth your time
well worth your money and indie films of
course always need your support let me
know what you think on Twitter at Alicia
Malone or in the comments below and I'll
see you again next week
[Music]